can you take us through what whiteness
means okay so
the the notion of whiteness i suppose
the best way to to think about it is a
system of power
right so it's um and this is coming from
critical race
this is the phrase that they always use
whiteness it's been analogized with the
concept with the augustinian idea
of original sin uh it doesn't actually
specifically pertain to well there's an
ambiguity
it doesn't specifically pertain to the
color of your skin the whiteness
it more pertains to a complicity in a
system of whiteness
a system of oppression on the basis of
race right
so for this is why for instance
very confusingly when there was that
story in america when the uh the the uh
the asian boys i think one of them
urinated on a black school girl
and and attacked them it was a kind of a
sort of
it was a horrible attack okay um they
were described because they weren't
white
perpetrators they were described as
enacting whiteness
in other words whiteness is a way that
you oppress
people of color a system of oppression
and that
you don't necessarily therefore have to
be white you could be
you could be white adjacent which is the
phrase that i
i started using last year as a joke
through titania
and now people are using it and i
started thinking did i invent this but i
probably didn't i
it probably was just there in the ether
you know it's because undiscovered
knowledge
yeah i mean you can because you can't
anticipate this stuff you can't that's
that's the problem
and and because fascist adjacent had
become so popular i just thought i'll
start calling
black people who don't have who are
conservatives say white adjacent
as a joke and now i'm actually seeing it
everywhere and it's really bothering me
i want to work out if i did invent that
i hope so um
but yeah so that's what whiteness so
therefore it's giving another example
um and of course there's all sorts of
books and tracks written about
whiteness and and trying to uh give it
the illusion that this is something that
is thought through
and and and sophisticated sophisticated
that is
it's two you know they load it with this
jargon in order to give the impression
that it's too complicated
for you to understand so you better just
accept hand it over to us
you made you made the analogy that um
the same reason as to why
the church didn't want the bible
translated
into common parlance back in the middle
ages
it's why they burnt tinder at stake
because you translate the bible it means
that they
all of a sudden the power is is is
devolved to the masses it means they can
interpret scripture
for themselves and that matters you know
you don't have you can't just say well
you can't have a priest just say well
you've got to do what i say because i'm
the only one who can read the sacred
texts you know
that is the equivalent of what's
happening here so the academics are
saying well and you see all the time
when people get into
when you your average person gets in an
argument with one of these crazy
academics on twitter
they'll say well actually i'm an expert
in this and they'll throw all this
jargon down
and they'll frighten people away and if
you know actually
don't worry about it because they're
talking bollocks they really are
all this comes from is is these these
things are slogans
that that that are used instead of
serious thought processes
and they are they're not to be taken
seriously so don't worry about it just
get them
also you should remind them that if
they're unable to express their point
with any degree of clarity
they're not expressing their point well
that's that's the other thing
but the mark of a it's the mark of a
genius to explain a complex thing in a
simple way is the mark of a charlatan
to explain a complex a simple thing in a
complex way
very nice did you just come up with that
no i found it on twitter probably but
not in your world so yeah you were
saying another example of whiteness well
just to give another example of the
of the way in which uh the social
justice people and the critical race
people
play on these ambiguities is that they
can say that all white people are
complicit in whiteness by virtue of the
color of their skin and they can also
say that people who are non-white are
also complicit in the system
if they if they are not actively
anti-racist remember for these people
isn't the dichotomy of racist or not
racist
because if you're not racist that's
another form of racism the dichotomy is
actually racist or anti-racist which
means you are proactively
uh conceding your own complicity in
these systems
and and attempting to decolonize these
systems right so it's not good enough
just not to be a racist person to be
good to be a good person who
who doesn't ever say or do or support
anything racist
that's not enough you've got to be an
anti-racist right
so you've got all that going on and then
but then they will play on and make it
racial
so then you've got like the resisting
whiteness uh
conference that was at edinburgh
university where they said explicitly
that in the q and a section at the end
white people were not allowed to put
their hands up and ask
questions so well in that case you are
making whiteness explicitly about skin
color
and in that circumstances what do you do
for your mixed race can you speak in a
low speed how much
how much whiteness are you allowed to
yeah did you get like do you get like
half a question
or or uh you know how do we and also
we're all
mongrels of various races so how much do
you get to speak do i have to have a dna
test to decide how much i can speak so
on the one hand they like the fact that
it alludes specifically to race and skin
color
and on the other hand they will deny
that it does and that race is a social
construct and all the rest of it so
it plays on the ambiguity it plays on it
it's in the same way that
they they play on the idea of of social
justice and liberalism
and they play on people's good natures
and good intentions
in order to get what they want i think
it's absolutely it's absolutely
ghastly so you can have for instance uh
academics who talk about how
uh whiteness is evil and we must abolish
whiteness as we've seen
from a number of i think there was a
cambridge academic who said exactly that
but of course what she's doing is she's
she's enjoying the fact that she can
have a pop of white people
but then she can defend herself by
saying yes but when i say whiteness i'm
talking about this oppressive system
that i've sort that i believe in this
magical system that we all us
fellow academics talk about amongst
ourselves so you can have it both ways
um it's it's really it's really bad it's
like the
the old-school um closet racist comedian
that would make
overtly racist jokes and then say just a
joke mate i'm only i'm i'm
only joking or the same as the the guy
who is vehemently anti-gay
but if you watch put put some gay porn
in front of him and stick him in front
of an mri he's got
much more of an arousal response than
anybody else in the room right exactly
the lady don't protest
too much the oldest trick in the book
isn't it but the bullies always used to
say it's just a joke you know and that's
and and
of course real comedians think through
their jokes carefully and decide whether
or not they are justified or not and and
so
yeah that absolutely it's it's a it's a
good analogy actually
you